hi I'm shadi Hamid I'm the director of
research at the Brookings Doha center so
I just was actually speaking on the
panel on the role of social media so we
had a very interesting discussion and
when we kind of think about the role
that youth can play and obviously young
people are the ones who are most
effectively using social media whether
it's Twitter or Facebook I think the
long-term question is what is what is
this ultimately going to lead to our
young people going to be able to
reconsider and alter the existing power
structures in the Arab world and that
can be economic structures it can be
political structures I think one risk
now is that we have this sort of exotic
vacation of youth and social media and
we see it as being a kind of fat and we
want to put young people up on a
pedestal but the real question is how do
you bring you into the power structures
so it's not just a matter of young
people advising or saying their opinion
and all of that but we need young people
who are actually the ones making policy
decisions who actually do play prominent
roles in major companies in the region
and that is going to be the real engine
of change but if we just kind of put
them to the side and say young people
what do you think that is not a
long-term strategy